[Music]
hey guys it's Jonah here you're probably
watching this video because you would
like to know your body type and how you
should work out and eat correctly in
order to achieve the best results we are
all created differently but equally just
as beautiful typically there are three
body types so there are the ectomorph
mesomorph and endomorph your genetic
predisposes you to one of the three body
types you can't change that however with
the right workout plan meal plan hard
work and dedication you can work and get
closer to another body type so very few
of us fall perfectly into one of the
three categories so as you watch this
video you might discover that you are a
mix of two body types but let's just
work with understanding the three body
types and how you can work and exercise
and eat correctly according to your body
type some of the information in this
video is based on the woman's fitness
specialist cause I did with the National
Academy of Sports Medicine & ASM so if
you would like to go into more detail to
learn about healthy living especially to
help others to get healthy the NASM is
currently offering a 14-day free trial
to get online personal training costs
and I have to share this opportunity
with you guys because I think is an
excellent platform to kick-start your
fitness journey and career so if you're
interested link and more details is in
my description box so let's start by
understanding the ectomorph they are
naturally thin they have smaller bone
structure thinner limbs shorter upper
body longer legs and arms narrow feet
and hence basically there is a much
difference between the size of their
shoulders hips and waist they have very
little fat storage and a small amount of
muscle mass they have a very high
metabolism which makes it very difficult
for them to gain weight so just think of
the typical endurance athlete or your
skinny model working friends some of the
celebrities include
Kate Moss Keira Knightley Taylor Swift
Kate Middleton Justin Bieber and Jared
Leto if you're an ectomorph typically
your goal is to gain weight as for your
food intake in for high amount of carbs
moderate amount of protein and low
amount of healthy fat so think of
consuming between 50 to 55 percent of
carbs 25 to about 30% of protein and
about 20% of healthy fats the goal is to
eat a lot more and a half high calorie
intake than what you are currently
consuming right now so whatever that
you're consuming right now
you should eat 750 to 1000 calories more
per day a good foundation to start is
think about consuming between 2 to 2.5
grams of cups per pound of your body
weight and 1.5 grams of protein per
pound of your body weight so since your
metabolism is very high try to eat every
two to four hours it can be tough to
constantly eat and eat lots of food so
think about drinking your calories and
consume calorie dense food so here's a
typical meal for an ectomorph man 3 cups
of carb dense food 2 pumps of protein
dense food 2 fifths of vegetables and 1
thumb of fat dad's food as for the
ectomorph women two cups of carb dense
food one pump of protein dense food one
fist of vegetables and half a thumb of
fat dense food when it comes to
exercising your main focus is strength
training in for four to five sessions
per week and go for moderate to heavy
weights in between 6 to 10 reps per set
and take longer rest between sets so
about 1 to 2 minutes per form compound
movements compa movements are basic
exercises that works on several muscles
or muscle groups at once and because
compound movements recruit a large
number of muscle fibers it is the most
effective way to build muscle mass and
quickest to gain strength some of the
examples include squats lunges push-ups
bent over row
chin up deadlifts and more as for your
cardio reduced on your cardio so in
between 15 to 20 minutes 2 to 3 times
per week if you can treat your cardio as
your warmup to avoid burning too much
calories so cuddle is too important to
increase them in our and to improve
heart health I would recommend you to
watch my best tips to gain weight for
skinny women video so let's move on to
the next body type mass or more
typically they are known as the good
jeans
they have medium sized bone structure
and athletic body if they are active
usually they have a very nice
proportionate body with good amount of
lean muscles they have a high metabolism
but not as high as an actor moth and if
they maintain a healthy lifestyle eat a
well-balanced diet it is typically very
easy for them to maintain a healthy
weight they can put on weight if they
slack off but once they get back into
their fitness routine and it well the
weight comes off pretty easily as well
and if they work towards gaining lean
muscles it is easier for them as well so
some of the celebrities include Jennifer
Lawrence Halle Berry Rihanna
the rock and Arnold Schwarzenegger so if
you are a metamorph typically your goal
is to lean up so basically you want to
maintain your current body weight but to
lose some body fat and to add more lean
muscles so as for your food intake think
of a balance between cups protein and
healthy fat so it should roughly be 40%
of carbs 40% of protein and 20% of
healthy fats ask for your total calorie
intake you should be eating enough to
maintain your current body weight
however if your goal is to lose a little
bit of weight then reduce on your total
calories slightly so a typical meal for
a mesomorph man includes two cups of cup
dense food two pounds of protein dense
food two fists of vegetables and two
thumbs of fat dense food as for a
mesomorph women one cup of carb dense
food one pump of protein dense food one
fist of vegetables and one thumb of fat
dense food so it is pretty much a balun
of everything as for exercising you
should focus equally on both strength
and career training so when it comes to
strength training we want to combine
both compound and isolation movements
isolation movements are exercises that
only focus on one muscle group at one
time isolation is important if you're
looking to define and shape the muscles
in a more aesthetic manner so isolation
movements will help to develop the
muscles once you have built a certain
level of muscle mass hence it is
important to combine both compound and
isolation movements together some of the
examples include bicep curls tricep
extensions leg curls licks leg
extensions cup raises and more go for
moderate to heavy weights so in between
eight to chuck repetitions per set and
rest between 30 to 90 seconds per set
and aim to perform your strength
training three to four times weekly and
your cardio is equally just as important
so perform your cardio three to four
times weekly as well and have at least
45 to 60 minutes of quality workout
session and the final body type is the
endomorph and endomorph has larger bone
structure with higher amount of total
body mass and fat cells they have a soft
body appearance and are naturally curvy
they have low metabolism and usually
gain fat pretty easily so they have to
pay a lot more attention to the output
intake in order to get fit if they
maintain an active lifestyle they can
build a lot of muscle mass as well but
they will still have to watch over their
food intake in order to maintain a lean
body some of the celebrities include
Oprah Winfrey Jennifer Hudson Mariah
Carey Kim Kardashian Jonah Hill and Jack
Black
typically your goal is to lose weight
and you have a lower calf tolerance as
well what this means is that you should
reduce on your carb intake so just think
of low carbs high-protein and moderate
amount of healthy fat so it should
roughly be between 25 to 30% of carbs
40% of protein and 25 to 30% of healthy
fats I know most of you think that if
you want to lose weight you should redo
your fat intake in fact this is not true
if you want to lose weight reduce on
your carbs and eat a moderate amount of
healthy fats not the unhealthy fats so
eating a good amount of fish which are
high in omega-3 fatty acid olive oil and
also nuts can actually help with weight
loss this is because fat slows down the
digestive system which means keeping you
fuller for much longer and reduce
craving fat also burns fats so by
telling your body that you're getting a
constant supply of healthy fat your body
will be more willing to let go the fact
that it is currently holding so if your
goal is to lose weight don't go on a
low-fat diet instead reduce on your carb
intake but remember that fat is still
high in calories so consumed in
moderation as for your total calorie
intake you should be eating less than
what you are currently eating right now
but still enough for you to maintain an
active lifestyle so into eat smaller
portions but more regularly in order to
keep your metabolism on the higher end I
would encourage you to watch my how to
turn your calories to lose weight video
so a typical meal for an endo mothman
includes one cup of carb dense food two
pumps of protein Gans food two fifths of
vegetables and two to three tons of fat
dense food as for an endomorph women
half a cup of cup dense food one pump of
protein dense food one fist of
vegetables and one to two thumbs of fat
dense food as for your training include
compound movements with shorter rest in
between sets
besides the benefits of building
strength and increasing lean muscles
compound movements with shot arrests
will help to burn fat more effectively
so go for moderate weights between 8 to
15 reps per set and rest between 30 to
60 seconds in between sets you would
also want to include superset trainings
what this means is performing two
exercises back to back without resting
so for instance doing push-ups and bent
over row back to back without resting
this will help to burn more calories and
shed fat quicker interval and circuit
trainings are also very effective for
you which
basically what most of my workout videos
are structured upon and remember that if
your goal is to lose weight cardio
should be the core of your training mix
in with strength training so do not
neglect on your cardio so in for two to
three sessions of strength training per
week and four to five sessions of cardio
per week and go for at least 45 to 60
minutes of quality session cardio will
have to burn the extra calories strength
training will help to build knee muscles
increase mass and increase your
metabolism but remember that it all
still comes down to your food intake so
watch over your food intake do your
workout and you will start to lose
weight I would also encourage you to
watch my how much should I eat to lose
weight video so do you know what is your
body type
are you an ectomorph mesomorph or
endomorph or a mix between two let me
know in the comments below remember that
no matter what body type you are hard
work and dedication means everything so
with the right workout and no plans we
can all achieve our fitness goals so do
not blame it on the jeans direct links
to all the videos I've mentioned is
right at the end of this video so if you
find this video helpful be sure to give
it a thumbs up and share it with someone
who might benefit from this video all
the best
[Music]
you